serious trouble emerging into
veterinarian business in the form of a
mental health crisis 8 news now reporter
reporter here at Hearts Alive Village
it's been a struggle to staff vets for
various reasons but what many don't talk
about is the high suicide rates among
these doctors too so this is a very
special piece that we had made for a
very special woman Christy Stevens
executive director of Hearts Alive
Village showing 8 news now a piece of
artwork that was done in honor of a
veterinarian who committed suicide five
years ago her loss was absolutely tragic
and so we want to make sure that
everyone's reminded every day of her
sacrifice and that her Legacy truly
lives on
[Music]
a mental health crisis not many know
about except for those in the field who
endure the strenuous working conditions
day in and day out unfortunately I do
have friends and colleagues who have you
know committed suicide which is
unfortunate it's easy to get lost in
that why am I going through all this
it's so much to bear according to the
CDC one in six veterinarians have
considered suicide throughout their
career and between fifteen thousand and
eighteen thousand veterinarian openings
will go unfilled by 2031. they recruit
us hard because of the shortage I was
getting recruited my third year of vet
school from the lack of veterinarian
schools to low wages and high turnover
rate the ability to hire veterinarians
and vet techs has not been easy the
biggest thing for us is to retain who we
have and honestly it's been two years of
difficulty for us finding the right
veterinarian to fit what we're doing and
hard to lie village doing what they can
to combat the crisis even offering
unlimited off-site therapy to their
staff in need reporting near Cheyenne
and Decatur Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now